انخفاض كبير سجله البنك المركزي السعودي
في حجم التمويل العقاري السكني الجديد
المقدم للافراد من المصارف خلال الشهر
الماضي حيث انخفض بنسبه 55 في المئه
مقارنه بنفس الفتره من العام 2022
ومقارنه ايضا بشهر مارس الماضي فقد شهد
التمويل انخفاضا لثلاثه وبلغ حجم التمويل
العقاري للافراد خلال شهر ابريل اربعه
مليارات 105 ملايين ريال وفقا لبيانات
البنك المركزي السعودي
في الاستوديو ينضم الينا الخبير والمطور
العقاري ماجد العرابي الحاتي سيد مجدي
هذا الانخفاض
بهالوين انخفاض قياسي كبير مقلق كيف يمكن
توصيفه
والله اكيد من دور ارتفاع الفائده في
البنك الفيدرالي وكنا نتنبا انه بيكون
هناك انخفاض طبعا في الطلب على العقار
لانه ارتفاع البنك الفيدرالي مؤثر على
القطاع العقاري في كل الحال العالم
كون ان البنوك المحليه مرتبطه بالبنك
المركزي وبالتالي في ارتفاع الفائده يؤثر
في عمليه ارتفاع قيمه القرض
فائده القرض وبالتالي تقليص قيمه
القرض فهناك لا يمكن
للمواطن
القرض الذي
من البنك شراء وحده سكنيه موافقه في سوق
العقاري لان اليوم السوق يشهد ارتفاع
اسعار في اسعار
الوحدات السكنيه مقابل ارتفاع فائده في في
البنوك وش الحل في مثل هذه الحال لانه
كمان متوقع هتكون في الزياده يعني في
الفائده يعني خلل من خلال التوقعات ايضا
في البنك الفيدرالي خلال الفتره القادمه
وبالتالي فالمعدل سيتم زياده هذا هو اللي
شفت انا امس تقرير انه ما زال مصرين انه
خلال السنتين القادمه يظل مرتفع لتقليل من
التضخم في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وبالتالي سيؤثر على
الدول المرتبطه بالدولار
فهناك اشكاليه اما انه تنخفض الفائده من
خلال البنك الفيدرالي وارتباطنا به او
انخفاض الوحدات السكنيه اسعارها في السوق
السعودي واليوم شاهدنا انه فيك في حراك مع
المطورين في ليونه في عمليه
المفاوضات وجود هدايا وجود
[موسيقى]
يعني مغريات للمشتري لربما انه يعني
يحركون السوق شوي طب اذا استمرت هذه
المشكله نعم وين وين تتجه الازمه برايك
وهل يمكن ان يكون هناك حل لا بد يكون هناك
انخفاض في الاسعار في الاجتماع ان لم يكن
هناك انخفاض في اسعار الفائده فلابد يكون
هناك انخفاض في اشعار العقار لتوافق
القيمه القدره الشرائيه للمواطن تلمس انه
فيه هناك انخفاض في الاسعار في العقاري
يلائم حجم الارتفاع في الفائده الازمه
لجلسه تحصل مقارنه بدول اخرى يعني مثلا
على سبيل المثال يقارنوا في امريكا ان
هناك انخفاض كبير في اسعار العقار بالنظر
الى التغيرات اللي حاصله في الاسعار
الفائته يمكن احنا في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ممتاز ان هناك في حمايه للمواطن
في
انه القروض العقاريه بالذات ما تتبع البنك
او تتبع الفائده
الشبرالي في ارتفاع وانخفاض الفائده فهي
مثبته الى عشرين سنه تقريبا فهذه واحده من
ضمن الامان بالنسبه للناس اللي اقترضوا
هذول في امان يعني باذن الله لكن المقترض
الجديد الان اصبح القرض اللي بياخذه مثلا
بياخذ مليون البنك بيحسب عليه سبع مئه الف
فاصبح القيمه عاليه جدا نعم فائده عاليه
جدا وايضا قللت بقيمه القرض اذا كانت بنك
يعطيك مليونين اصبح الان يعطيك القرض
مليون فما تقدر تشتري وحده سكنيه من السوق
هنا اليوم في تغير حتى في المطور العقاري
اصبح
يستهدف الشريحه الاقل سعرا واليوم الحمد
لله يعني الشركه الوطنيه قاعدين نشوفها
تقدم خدمات جيده من خلال الاسعار اللي
قدمتها في الضاحيه اللي قدمها
قدمتها وزاره الاسكان فرسان
وتناسب هل في انخفاض في اسعار العق شايفه
مشهود
كنتيجه طبيعيه لهذه الحاله ركود موجود
انخفاض في الاطراف موجود
زي ما قلت لك اول ما كان فيه عمليه تفاوض
مع المطور في الوحدات السكنيه اليوم لا
اصبح فيه تفاوض في في هدايا فيه امور يعني
ثانيه بدات لانه اصبح يعني كان اولي يبيع
الوحدات السكنيه وباقي ما خلص الان تقعد
عند اربعه خمسه شهور ما قدر يبيعها
بعيد لك نفس السؤال اذا استمرت الامور
بنفس الشكل بنفس الوتيره يعني بالتالي
سنشهد ربما نتائج حتى وارقام قياسيه ربما
في في انخفاض نسبه القروض خلال الفتره
القادمه الاثر المتوقع والشوف في هذه
الحاله
الركود وين ممكن يوصل وهل ممكن ينسحب على
احنا نتكلم عن القطاع السكني فقط قطاعه
الثانيه
ليست لها علاقه بالقروض ولا
فالقطاع السكني اكيد لابد اجباري انه
ينخفض ان لم تنخفض
الفائده اليوم قاعدين حتى شفتوا في
التقرير اللي قدمته فيهم
الامس انه في ايضا انه وصلت مستهدفات
وزاره الاسكان الى تقريبا
يعني قربت الى تقريبا 67% يعني قربت
المستهدف اللي هو سبعين في المئه اللي
بيكون في عشرين ثلاثين وهذا واحد من ضمن
الجوانب اللي الحمد لله يعني قدمت فيها
الوزاره شوط كبير
الاجباري هنا لابد ان يكون فيه انخفاض في
في الاسعار يعطيك العافيه
شكرا لكل حاله الخبير المطور العقاري شكرا
جزيلا لك
باريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على
اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات